so you're pregnant again
yes I found I think it was the 14th like
August 14th I think or August 13th I
took the pregnancy test at my
job
man so what baby what's going on since
the last time you were here you uh so
you got housing I well I did get housing
from when I was in the Wine Guard with
the first baby with the my last baby but
um when I had got kidnapped and went
back to Vegas because of the kidnapping
thing I didn't want to get you know what
I'm saying hurt or nothing so I ran back
to Vegas and I lost my housing cuz they
was waiting on the maintenance to fix my
apartment and so the next day after I
went to Vegas I called my case manager
trying to get my birth certificate and
she told me oh like your apartment was
ready we had the keys the next day and
so I was like oh well I can't get back
out there I'm stuck in Vegas like you
know what I'm saying I don't have no
money to get back out there so she was
like oh well you know you know what I'm
saying like it it is what it is you just
have to get rematched if you come back
so now I'm back out here like a year
later
and it's been crazy now I've been I
dated this dude dropped out by from
through town pyu he turned out to be
like a big piece of [__] he cheated on
me then he [__] shows up with this
whole [__] that stabbed him then like I
left him and came back like two weeks
later and he seen a hickey on my neck
and tripped out like oh now I'm in love
with you all of a sudden but I just like
told him like how I felt that night
before and he was like oh yeah I don't
want no relationship like I got hoe in
my blood so I was like all right well
you got to stop [__] me so good so
like I don't know it's been like a super
crazy ride with him like back and forth
he like chased me like he's obsessed
with me I guess he says he's in love
with me and [__] and
then now in August like the 13th or 14th
I took the pregnancy test found out I
was pregnant
so here we are like but the dude keeps
beating on me and like I don't know I'm
trying to stay away from him but like
even if like if he just sees me in the
street he's going to try to beat me up
and [__] so I try my best to just avoid
that whole area on San Pedro and stuff
like stay out the way you know how you
making money
now yes you don't want me to say it I
don't want to say you can say whatever
you want no I don't want to say it yeah
you can use our imagination I'll be
doing different you know what I'm saying
wherever I can get I'll be finessing
different people mhm so this is baby
number this will be the fourth one but
the first one was a miscarriage so this
will really be the third living one and
the fathers are all black um no my first
baby daddy is white for the first the
miscarriage and then my first daughter
they're it's a white boy from Tennessee
and then the last two yeah one dude's
from Vegas and now this dude out here
he's black so yeah that's what be be my
second mix
baby you think you're going to lose this
one I hope not I'm I'm trying to stay
you know what I'm saying steer clear
like I'm trying to
just I ain't going to lie lately I've
been like this last week I've been
trying to get I've been trying to get
high some [__] like I don't know like
just pills and [__] and I don't know I
just it's good for the baby stressed out
yeah no I'm trying to stay away from it
though so I was clean for like a whole
two weeks and then when I I left I got
kicked out my apartment with my co
worker because drop out staking out
outside of his apartment building trying
to stalk me and stuff like he got me
kicked up out of there so I've been you
know what I'm saying like I was outside
for a few days I just started staying at
the Ellis like maybe four days ago five
days ago so like I've been you know what
I'm saying just like super stressed out
I don't know it's kind of like I want
this baby but I don't want this baby cuz
I don't want to be attached to that man
for like 18 years you know he's abusive
and is not not a good person I guess not
the he claims he loves me but that's not
the kind of love I know and not the kind
of love I want so I don't know that's
the only reason I don't want it but I'm
not going to you know what I'm saying I
couldn't kill it like it's my fault too
so I just got
to woman up I guess grow up it's time
for that um how old do you know but I
mean I'm 28 be 29 March yeah it's it's
time to it's time to grow up it I mean
everything happens for a reason so could
be a sign like hey look you got to stop
I'm tired of living this life and being
out here and not having nobody and are
you tired of it I'm tired of it I'm sick
of it there's nothing out here man
there's nothing there's nothing there's
a bunch and then like the [__] you see
like I'll be seeing super pretty females
that have burnt the [__] out like a week
month later I'm like bro you looked good
last week what happened to you like I
don't want to be like that I don't want
to be like that like I still got it
so you know my my teeth are [__] up
but that's nothing this it's it's an
easy fix for to go to the dentist to
swap meat to get a grill like it's
nothing to get veneers the insurance
will pay for that I just got to I need
to get myself situated I need to get
into housing I got to figure out I
called my case manager for the housing
place she told me to um contact her boss
which I tried to do called them over and
over again left messages but the lady
never answers her phone I don't know so
so you weren't on birth control when
this happened no I I wasn't on birth
control and I wasn't wearing protection
obviously I was dating the dude at the
time I wanted it like I didn't know he
didn't start abusing me until like
really after I found out I was pregnant
he started hitting on me and [__] I was
like first of all if you love somebody
you don't hit on can I give you can I
give you a tip darling yeah don't get
pregnant with a dude on Skid Row oh God
you know I know I didn't even really I
mean you know what I'm saying I was lost
I was digma I guess you could say I was
dig to the dick was good so I was like
oh yeah I need that but I don't and then
I should have known that like when he
cheated on me the first time but my dumb
ass wanted somebody
so I kept going
back and then after I found out I was
spring then he started abusing me like
hitting me like he damn near broke my
nose he tried to kick me in my stomach
he literally like the man is so crazy he
ran out of gas and come to my house and
threw my lizard in my FL out the window
and try to beat my ass then kicked in my
door over there at my other spot and got
me kicked up out of there like it's
crazy the man's really
childish he you're living a Crazy Life
yeah I just want to get into the housing
I need to figure out the SRO
situation they said the company that
matched me last time when I was in the
wiard they're no longer I guess an
organization so I don't know who my
point of contact is or how to get a hold
of
nobody so so I've been trying to call
them the SRO people I tried to call
lha nobody can tell me nothing yeah
California makes it easy for people that
don't really want to get their lives
together they just they'll give you a
roof over your head and everything I
mean I want to get my life together I
really don't want to be down here I
rather be like you know with the with
the Section 8 you can go anywhere so I
really rather be like I don't know
anywhere Hollywood anywhere anywhere but
here M it doesn't matter to me I don't
want to be on SC row though
but this is where you've been for how
long now yeah well I left and I came
back because I don't have nobody I don't
have nowhere to go like I can't I could
go home to Tennessee but then what my
family don't mess with me out there so
be homeless out there like they don't
care about me I'm just grateful they
take care of my babies my two babies you
know what I'm saying I'm not going to
lose this one I'm definitely not going
to give this one up I'm not I can't I
need like something something has to
make me if you if you're using you're
going to lose it yeah but I I mean I
about to stop for real cuz I don't I
only been using for like two days I've
just been stressed out and depressed
like when you don't have nobody and you
don't have like that's all I know you
know is to turn to drugs cuz that's all
I've done my whole life cuz I don't I
don't know nothing else nobody ever
showed me nothing how many months along
are you I just found out in August so
it's probably like two months three
months an abortion is not an option I
mean it's illegal now not here yeah it
is not in California since when they
said it was
illegal oh God that's what they said I
was like I'm abort this [__] but
I don't even really believe in abortions
but I don't need that stress of this man
for 18 years and then what if it's the
sign to make me grow up I don't
know if I aborted them what I'm just
going to keep using because I have
nothing and
nobody maybe it's my time Mark it's this
this is this is the sign from the
seventh sign from God you know like hey
you got to grow the [__] up like you
can't just keep living this how many
kids you going to fit out there in the
world and no this is only my third kid
but I mean been other like signs from
God like he you need you have 10 more
kids I don't want to work this baby
maker going in a play you're not doing
anything to stop having no after this
like the baby maker got to go in a play
pin it's time to get uh my tub's hot
ablation surgery something has to go
talk is cheap I can't do it talk is
cheap no I can't do it I can't keep
having kids you're doing it I'm not no
more yes you are shut up Mar yes I am
but I can't okay it was one time the man
is crazy I can't do it he [__] me too
good and then you feel me fed me some
[__] wet dreams we'll do an update
in a year and you'll have the same story
to tell no I won't don't say that Mar
prove me wrong all right I'm going to
prove you wrong please I will all right
baby all right great seeing you again
you too thank you you still look great
thank you I hope you uh figure this out
thank you I don't think the answer is
down here for you though me too I just
need some help that's it just some
direction somebody to help me
tell me what to do like help me I don't
know you feel me I don't know I don't
know I I've never had nobody to help me
do nothing everybody in my life was
always told me the wrong thing was your
dad was your dad around when you no I
never had a dad he was always in prison
my whole life I met him when I was 18
and on God I forgave him for not being
there my whole life cuz I always wanted
to be his little girl but then when I
met him he came to Tennessee to
Knoxville to picked me up first of all
this was the first [__] up he pulled up
in a stolen U-Haul truck with a [__]
that he claimed to be a fiance but the
[__] was 3 months younger than me now
this is your fiance I'm your daughter
and you want to pick me up and take me
to Miami Florida to go work in a circus
or a carnival because that's all you
know is carnivals but here my dumb ass
is want to be daddy's little girl so
yeah let's go I got money [__] it why
not oh God we went out there he left me
stranded he robbed me and left me
stranded then they came back a week
later and his little girlfriend went in
there and got a job with the same people
that I went in there and got a job with
and they borrowed $400 from my boss and
and then they ran off with that so it
made me look
bad yeah that's how my dad is you know
my mom's dead now so she been dead since
2018 so it's been like and in my other
family I don't have nobody I never had I
don't have brothers sisters I mean I got
younger brother and younger sister but
what are they going to do for me they
don't even know their self they they
don't have no I mean they got my aunt
and uncle that but they don't have
nothing to do with me I don't even talk
to nobody I really don't it's crazy they
all like
they didn't even tell me the truth about
my mom in her death I don't get no ashes
that's the crazy part like I had to file
for an autopsy report with the medical
examiner that at the hospital in
Tennessee and they just emailed it to me
so recently it's 16 pages long I I can't
read it like it's too much I can't even
I keep crying I can't it breaks my
heart it's sad it's pathetic but it's I
mean it is what it is um I've been on my
own my whole life so so I don't really
need them I just need somebody to help
me guide me on the right path to get my
stuff in you never had Role
Models you never had much guidance no I
just need to get I need somebody to help
me out here to help me get direction
tell me how to get you know what I'm
saying to the SRO people figure out what
I got to do about house and help me get
a ID that like just simple little [__]
like simple [__] with that I mean with
me like drugs is out of sight out of
mind if I be somewhere like away from
down here away from this [__] I'm not
going to want to do drugs cuz I don't
it's not in my face it's not something
to do I don't I stay in my house and
watch TV all day
like you feel me like I don't this [__]
is just a social life it's just to
mingle it's like everybody's doing it
down here what else is there to do
there's nothing to do down here Dad or
what sell [__] I don't sell [__] it's
not me
so you give it away no I just don't I
mean I don't really even give it away I
just was in a relationship with this guy
like the other baby my last baby daddy
yeah he came from one I say cuz he says
some freaky [__] but like I'm just I
guess I'm a freak I don't know [__] that
was just you know what I'm saying out of
spite that was in Vegas like what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas I guess
that's what they say yeah or goes on
Facebook you know all right baby thank
you so much I wish you all the luck in
the
too